this is basically a filleted side of  salmon it's been taken off the bone and  now  skin off  pick up your knife a really nice broad  flexible  knife lift up  base of the towel and then just Nick a  little bit at the end there twist the  knife almost as if it's horizontally  underneath the salmon cool the skin and  you slice  there's some underneath and let the  knife do the work now get your skin  flip it back over  check you're not leaving too much salmon  on top of the skin pull it back  and nice and slowly get the skin wrap  around your fingers  pull the salmon towards you and then  just all the way through  lay that down  one nicely skin salmon